in mother crazy news but a mother crazy
mother mother mother mother submitted by
Jenny loves JK what doesn't want Jenny
Jenny [ __ ] tired of Jenny [ __ ] you
know like Jenny is a really common name
for like there's fit nummies Jenny's
Chinese James oh that's true oh yeah
American American Jenny it could be it
could be Jenna H loves JK Australian
Jenny's half of all Vietnamese girls are
named Vivian and tell you that right now
really Abby I don't know why they always
think they're kids Vivian town we're
talking about Jenny's right now Gina
Vivian comfort because we're somewhat
Vietnamese were here a daycare provider
who attempted to hang a toddler by a
noose is spared from jail
why [ __ ] probation what you should
blame buy a noose like to kill them
yeah know better what happened yeah
alright so back in November 2016 this
nanny named Natalia who's 43 years old
she she's Ukrainian yeah how'd you know
Natalia is it sounds like it from
Ukraine and and the news tactic very
yuki alright so we hung a 16 month-old
almonds in her basement with tight what
and so when this father who was dropping
off because she had a daycare in her
home when he was dropping off his
three-year-old daughter she opened the
door and said call the police I did
something bad and he could hear the
crying from the basement so he ran down
there he saw the little kid he picked up
a little kid took him back to his home
told his wife to call the police so then
that's when Natalia she got in her gold
minivan
oh definitely gold it sounds like a
Russian villain our Ukrainian villain
I'm trying to paint the whole thing
formation as well close our call record
something once you said gold
I started thinking of unfortunate events
like everything is uh weird colors no
champagne
Oh people love that [ __ ] toilet
yeah so that's uh I mean they're calling
it it's all very sparkly gold one like a
bowling I should have been more specific
god damnit champagne no don't be
specific does this you gotta [ __ ] your
back then you get this guy yeah if you
didn't say gold you give us details but
something didn't matter as she walked
past the blue skies in turn that matters
because you've asked me questions for
everything you would ask me what color
the van was what's the converse shoes
what's the color of shoes I don't know
that I would tell you if I knew it thank
you anyway she gets in Iran she ends up
striking a pedestrian she's she's a
sketch is kind of go to me she she ended
up dragging some like stretchers walks
what oh yeah and she also hit a
bicyclist how'd she get probation and
then she went to she went to a bridge
and there was people around that stopped
her from jumping her adult son was
saying that she had a very abusive
relationship with their father oh when
she was in court she was reading out
this statement in Russian saying all the
abuses that her husband inflicted upon
her and her children since they write to
the u.s. from the Ukraine back in 2006
he hit and threatened to kill her drove
the family into financial ruin forced
her to work despite her psychological
struggles that prevented her from
getting medical attention because she
would tell them that she just didn't
feel right so she ran a daycare because
he forced her to pretty much is what's
happening but she also said I don't want
to push this trouble crime on to my
husband I just want to explain what
happened your honor my children need me
give me a chance to resume a normal life
but the judge said she has to live with
her adult son
she received a 10-year probationary
sentence with credit for the 20 months
that she's spent in jail she also has
court-ordered mental health treatment
and electronic home monitoring for at
least two months she cannot have
unsupervised contact with her daughters
or minors because she has three other
children ages 2 7 and 10 oh my
she dragged someone with her car to look
what about that person did anyone die no
one died the baby didn't die no one died
I didn't get all the newer information
you got like she even told the dead
that's that help to the little boy she
was like if you hurry he might survive
like she's not gonna go down she had a
mental break for sure a mental break out
this isn't out of like evil
maliciousness yeah I think she said like
I couldn't take it anymore yeah she was
pretty much I drove to this so the judge
said that but to hang a child would
Patti hold ya give to like think about
that [ __ ] it's crying screaming and
you're still wrapping it around and like
go [ __ ] I mean break a [ __ ] laundry
machine yeah rationally right and then
if there's a crying baby mental
breakdown I break walls like noble
people saying oh that's like extreme
anger but this is like she [ __ ]
something in her snap okay that's true
cuz mental breakdown means
oh I kill people watch out and [ __ ] yeah
the judge said that this is a perfect
storm of circumstances that would
probably never happen again
so she's her husband going to jail for
causing that unless she presses charges
and what has to pay right so what about
the kids right how does the yeah the
baby's mom or dad a feel that baby is
traumatized
I would kill that woman oh my god I
would I would sleep people can't make up
their own punishments like okay well you
don't have to pay but you get to sit in
the chair and I get to hit you in the
face with the baseball yeah exactly
Oh kill them with the sock kill them
with laundry items oh yeah you get a
real long stocking and in bucket fill it
with coins
yeah he's smack her over the head or
entire tire up with it that's some
crazy-ass [ __ ] man that's weird I'm kind
of conflicted like yeah she should be
punished but it also kind understand
like [ __ ] you got [ __ ] like you I mean
that's most people though you know
people that snap and all that there's
but but the parents should still be able
to punch her in the face well so hit the
further inflicting more mental issues
yeah yeah I tell you like as a mom here
I'm like I want to let you live and get
help but also like man you like that
that child is damaged for life
metoya their psychological issues
marisol like you you ruins a whole life
like it's a domino effect because now
they can say they were abused and then
they got hurt now they can do this
exactly it's the same shit's has to stop
somewhere I would say stop at the root
of the problem kill her and her husband
well I mean the kids know gonna already
hear it he endure the trauma
so you're saying kill the husband I mean
kill the baby too cuz that's gonna be
enough I mean the husband where does it
stop but you know I was innocent though
the kid was innocent little lady got
hurt and passed it right but yeah right
but then so going off of his logic right
you know there's a something's already
damaged want to get rid of the oh I'll
preserve her and a [ __ ] trial
something chamber and then like you know
those freeze chambers yeah and then when
he grows up or she grows up and they're
like okay we've been saving this for
your birthday what do you want to do and
then they get to choose I think this is
their prison system really is about
rehabilitation at this point I'm like or
is it just kind of like possibly know
this in America is America she's usually
moved from Ukraine oh wow yeah she let
her in America Wow they didn't do
anything illegal it's just she had a
mental breakdown after all these years
living in America yeah and then that
bicyclist that she hit they had to put a
rod surgically implanted to spare him
from MGP see that's what I'm saying as
if she damaged so many people's lives
that the the car at all she gets a
stroke we shouldn't matter that you are
mentally unstable like that you still
should have to have some she needs
something that reminds her at least pay
for it she need a pregnant lady loved
the car that she was driving that she
hit was driven by a pregnant lady see
monetary she got his life and she's not
a danger to public yeah
she needs to [ __ ] have like ankle
bracelet that's tied to a chair and she
can't move anywhere yes something she's
gonna be having a break bracelet or
Inglot participation but you could go
anywhere though it's just electronic
exactly you should put her in a hot one
of those padded room hospitals like
commit her man this is a like a [ __ ]
that is crazy that's why I'm never gonna
find out kids they're not gonna go to no
[ __ ] child daycare they're not gonna
even go to school I'm putting a body kit
I can already picture his kids with
[ __ ] knotted hair and like they speak
no English they just run they build the
butt Hut the back this is how children
should be given ooh yeah their feet are
all black make a list but they'll be
healthy it was crazy because that 16
month old she had only been there for a
month and not even abused so the other
kids that she was watching was fine well
that's the only one that is being
reported oh she was just like [ __ ] this
kid in particular like maybe he was
crying and that's what like oh I think
he might have been the first one there
maybe and that's like David so unlucky
cool baby would have been that gateman
oh yeah but I've done it himself though
don't trust nobody I don't know if I can
take care of my kids sometimes people
don't got a choice though yes you know
no but I do
I rather live in a car be homeless and
wait until my kid is strong enough or
annoys the [ __ ] out of me and then
they're gone either or so within two is
yeah right they're 16 you're ready to be
a dad if they're 16 and ready for to
fend for themselves go on your way
[ __ ] that this is the real world
you're gonna live in a car so 16 though
the kids sister can 16 but they know
we're gonna go around we're gonna go
yeah and then ya aini Katie milk you
know just gonna be around for 16 years I
like
we're gonna go around we're gonna park
behind a wall mom we're gonna be around
you know smart street smart you're gonna
have a bullet
I already picture you with those that
hair and a [ __ ] moly one oh my god
yep it's gonna be an all Jean everything
[Applause]
[Music]